she knows I told her you didn't tell me
I figured it out how's it going
everybody it's Warren and we have a very
very short new clip of spider-man far
from home and in this short funny clip
we see that MJ has fully discovered that
Peter Parker is in fact spider-man
we have been teased this in the last
spider-man far from home trailer that
came out but as you can see in this
video she actually sees him in his
spider-man stealth suit Ned walks in and
of course he knows that Peter Parker is
spider-man and he starts freaking out
but then Peter Compton now by saying
that he told her but in reality in the
movie she is going to figure it out
somehow which wouldn't exactly be too
hard everytime trouble appears Peter
Parker disappears and then spider-man
shows up and not to mention they are now
in a foreign country on a school trip
and spider-man is still showing up so it
wouldn't exactly be too hard to figure
out that Peter Parker is spider-man
which MJ has obviously done in
spider-man far from home which is
something that happens pretty frequently
both in the comics and in the movies
that we've seen in each spider-man movie
that we've gotten so far including
spider-man into the spider-verse
MJ knows that Peter Parker is spider-man
in most the movies or the comics they
are together so it makes perfect sense
it's looking like spider-man far from
home is going to be a very important
movie for the MCU moving forward not
only is our beloved Iron Man now gone
and Peter Parker is working with shield
but it appears that Marvel is
introducing the multiverse into the MCU
and this just opens up the MCU to the
possibility of so many different
characters to enter so moving forward
spider-man aka Peter Parker is going to
be a very important character in the MCU
and now his secret identity is known by
not only Aunt May Ned but also MJ so let
me know what you think about this super
short clip and let me know how you think
MJ figures out that Peter Parker is
spider-man let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and a reminder
do not forget to subscribe to my channel
at the 400,000 subscriber Mike I will be
picking three winners and each winner
will get to choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection to
enter all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Applause]